[Musique]
il
bien le bonjour chez vous aujourd'hui
nous sommes à 3600 km à l'est de moscou
dans la république de l'altaï située aux
frontières entre le kazakhstan la
mongolie et la chine
l'altaï en langue locale veut dire
montagne doré elle est composée d'une
trentaine de massifs montagneux riche en
minerai et trois de ces sites sont
référencés au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
la principale activité la région et le
tourisme en l'air vivifiant de la
montagne l'eau pure les herbes
médicinales attire ici chaque année
environ un million de personnes à côté
de ceux qui pratiquent un tourisme actif
d'autres viennent pour améliorer leur
santé et aujourd'hui nous allons faire
la connaissance de quelqu'un qui s'y
connaît en la matière il accueille les
touristes et partage sa connaissance à
des traditions locales culturelles du
chamanisme
notre invité à échanger ses bureaux de
l'hexagone avec l'immensité de l'altaï
s'appelle herry friis et aujourd'hui
c'est notre guide allons faire sa
connaissance
salut jan erik en chantier bat moment ça
me fait plaisir d'être là c'est
incroyable on se dit bonjour alterne on
dit bonjour à l'intérieur un bon couple
comme ça c'est comme ça c'est magnifique
la nature la force de la nature ici
fâché oui je déménage demain il va
falloir que tu racontes qu'est ce que tu
fais en altaï commente a atterri en
altaï écoute comment j'ai atterri alors
d'abord la nature oui intacte l'eau pure
l'air pur un véritable paradis 1
pourquoi je suis là la jeunesse de tout
ça c'est que mon épouse natasha et les
ukrainiennes l'a vécu jusqu'à l'âge de
20 ans en ukraine et ensuite elle est
venue en france et quand les enfants on
était un peu plus grand quand il avait
l'âge de voyager natacha nous a proposé
de découvrir la russie donc on a
commencé tu sais comme par étape par
étape a donc moscou saint pétersbourg
samara et puis de plus en plus loin il
ya cause le baïkal et à en donner
l'altaï et donc on a dit un jour ben
écoutez on est tous d'accord les enfants
tout ça on s'en va en tant que
l'expatriation est bon on y va et puis
on est parti comme ça va c'est
incroyable tout vendu on a tout vendu on
est parti et on s'est installé nous un
tout petit village pour moi j'ai fait
100 km la de cornouaille ça oui combien
combien il reste encore à faire il nous
reste cinq kilomètres pour arriver à de
cheval qui est le
le quand même la ville d'une part une
ville une ville près nature d'accord un
point important ici dans la région et
ensuite on a 15 km à faire dans les
montagnes pour arriver au village on y
va on y va aller avec grand plaisir je
tenais haut niveau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eric c'est quoi cette voiture est ce que
c'est une boucle qu'annoncé s'affaissa
exactement moi je dis wazi qui avait
plus particulièrement si je parle en
français j'ai un suppositoire
garde pourquoi cette voiture parce que
c'est alors ces deux choses pour notre
activité quand on accueille des invités
et bien c'est déjà très pratique pour
emmener les personnes dans les montagnes
qui passe partout et en même temps ça a
été un moyen pour faire accepter par les
russes par la mairesse pourquoi parce
qu'un français qui roulent en voisine et
son gauchement fier en fait tu comprends
ouais tu viens de france oui arrive avec
quand même une certaine qualité de
l'idée des voitures un peu moins
rustique qu'est ce qui t'amène ici
attends attends attends attends attends
qu on précise apple la qualité de vie ce
à quoi ça tient juste au matériel ou tu
comprends ça je vais pas aller plus loin
mais quelque part voilà moi je suis venu
chercher une qualité de vie ici que que
sous des apparences occidentales on
pourrait croire être vraiment là bas et
j'ai trouvé ce que je cherchais ici
c'est autre chose allons-y
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi j'adore cet endroit parce que c'est
un village perdu dans les montagnes donc
tenir en dehors dehors des civilisations
sans être trop loin tu vois mais c'est
le dernier village avant la taïga donc
c'est le bout du chemin et ça ça pour
moi c'est hyper important c'est ce que
je connaissais pas en france en france
j'habitais fontainebleau forêt de
fontainebleau en forêt de fontainebleau
tu fais 5 en fait il ya toujours
quelqu'un un chemin un truc ici tu sais
que là à partir de lierre juste derrière
les maisons tu as des milliers de
kilomètres c'est sauvage c'est
émotionnellement très très très fort de
savoir que l'ail et les ours que là il
ya les loups
qu'est ce que c'est sa maison donc
qu'est ce que c'est c'est assez amusant
si ma maison c'est notre maison de
l'autre au début c'était très simple
c'était un garage ici pour manger les
voitures pour l'hiver est fini à 1
banias et puis finalement avec les
cheveux qui tombent même entouré ici on
dit oui d'accord mais tu es sûr mais tu
veux faire un bâillon mais tu voudrais
pas faire un truc un peu différent un
peu nanana un peu plus donc on s'est
laissé emmener tu crois pas que tu
pourrais faire pour retenir qu'ils
viennent de france et puis finalement
ils ont participé une fois ci mais en
fait on n'a pas aux vrais en a qu'on
crée quelque chose tu vois c'est on a on
n'avait pas du tout imaginé ce soit
comme ça et franchement on est vachement
content si c'est pas un magnin c'est
quoi ah oui alors moi je suis venu de
france avec une expérience de coach on
estime de soi confiance en soi et qui
est en tant que praticien pnl j'avais
appris aussi des protocoles qu'on
appelle de pnl ckoi excuse moi j'étais
la programmation neuro linguistique en
gros c'est qu'avec les mots la parole tu
peux effectivement pour reprogrammer des
programmes et ton cerveau et d'une
certaine façon d'aborder ton cerveau et
de lui expliquer certaines choses parce
que lui ton dans son dans sa tour
d'ivoire et si tu sais pas y aller et là
on apprend et y aller en fait et tu peux
effectivement changé plein de choses tu
peut guérir c'est de la médecine
alternative c'est ça ouais alors on va
pas parler du risque comme s'impliquait
on va pouvoir aider
certaines personnes à avoir une vie plus
confortable
ça n'est pas guérir guérir c'est réservé
aux médecins la médecine officielle tout
ça tout ça ce fait cela faisait une
grande salle en fait pour aussi
développé certaine gymnastique
qui élimine le stress et puis une fan de
massage et puis voilà oui cci chambre
donc à une partie des jeunes gens là
aussi pour recevoir des personnes
effectivement nos invités ensuite
devient des habitants du village puisque
on a aujourd'hui deux français qui
conscients à acheter et donc ça devient
le visage des français dans la région tu
vois ces voix là c'est très rigolo ça
est en fait pour les montagnards d'ici
nous sommes leur français alors
attention on est leur français donc et
comme une sorte de mythe protection
aussi très rico
[Musique]
allez yann je te présente son épouse
natasha rejoint d'achat cellule
hooligans tu parles je parle français
oui très bien français se trouveraient
d'accord d'accord c'est pas très bien
pour ça je le sens on est chez toi on
est chez vous oui c'est ça qu'on tombe
de topiary maison qu'est ce qu'il ya là
bas tu peux montrer oui j'ai démontré
que l'on va s'installer on va discuter
un peu ici à la maison que tu te sentes
chez toi
tu veux danser curieux d'entre vous
explique tout ça je sais pas je vois des
choses que je ne voit pas habituellement
chez les autres alors je me oui je me
pose des questions bon bah écoute vierge
marie oui la vierge marie qui a une
représentation d'une vierge qui se
trouve l'abbaye de fontenay près de
l'est pas très loin de béziers en fait
mais l'idée si tu veux ici les
symboliques alors là moi je te parle de
ce qui me concerne moi la symbolique
c'est que dans la nature tu peux
retrouver les mêmes symboles en fait la
nature en fait c'est ma croyance et
c'est la croyance aussi ici des chemins
de la nature s'exprime souvent au
travers des morceaux de bois et des
morceaux de pierres alors après moi j'ai
tu dis ça je m'y intéresse d'autres sont
persuadés de ça mais je trouve ça très
très très étonnant de d'avoir des
messages des symboles comme ça aussi
clair dans la nature en ville
[Musique]
dites-moi les amis sept maisons les
maisons qui sont à côté où les avaient
achetés comme ça vous les avez
construite c'est quoi l'histoire n'ont
rien n'existait existe ici hormis une
petite maison
traditionnelle russe mais en très très
très mauvais état qui appartenait à un
monsieur décédé michel l qui était d'un
chaman ici comment vous chauffez enfin
c'est le chauffage c'est ce qu'on nous
compare avec bon la france comment ça se
passe ici le chauffage l'hiver bois on a
une chaudière à bois et charbon d'accès
selon s'il fait très froid tu utilises
charbon s'il fait moins froid le bois et
c'est une activité presque à temps plein
il faut voir et décoller les verts et le
tout noir charbon oui c'est lui qui fait
le tue mais le charbon la nuit aussi
la nuit mais peut-être parfois plusieurs
fois par jour
j'imaginais tue c'est l'hiver ici sous
la neige avec tous les livres que t'as
pas réussi à lire depuis les dernières
vingt dernières années et tranquillement
à côté de la cheminée en fait non c'est
pas du tout ça en fait je passe beaucoup
de temps à gérer le chauffage parce
qu'en même temps bon il ya la chaudière
elle même que tu dois changer mais aussi
le bois a préparé le charbon à préparer
mais ça fait partie des activités
importantes au village ça fait partie de
ton quotidien si tu parlais de que tu ne
t'en tu n'y es pas le l'hiver
effectivement mais vous avez des loisirs
qu'est ce que vous faites l'univers on
est beaucoup on en profite en après les
après les heures passées au chambranle
est
une question qui me brûlait les lèvres
au delà des films non mais internet vous
avez internet oui c'est parce que c'est
quand même un satellite et le débit est
pas sûr ça marche mais je dire ça
évidemment ça marche moins vite que qu'à
moscou enfin voilà c'est plus lent et
plus
ça dépend des jours ça dépend des jours
maintenant ça ça dépend des jours si la
couverture nuageuse et j'ai l'impression
jeunesse paraissait heureux oui
l'internet finale mais c'est un paradis
ici c'est le paradis non mais on est
venu ici pas pour soi rester en france
et fritz est né en 1967 à fontainebleau
son père est cadre dans une grande
société industrielle française eric pas
son enfance dans un environnement
naturel en lisière de la forêt de
fontainebleau puis eric commence à
travailler à la caisse d'epargne d'île
de france où il gravit peu à peu les
échelons jusqu'à devenir en 2008
directeur d'un important groupe d'
agences bancaires en seine et marne à
cette époque il découvre le coaching et
décide de se former dans cette
spécialité et obtient un certificat à
l'institut français de programmation
neuro linguistique il prend tellement
plaisir dans cette nouvelle voie qu'il
décide de démissionner afin de créer sa
propre société de coaching à paris il
propose alors ses services dans le
milieu de l'entreprise et de la banque
tout en continuant à se former et à
s'intéresser aux techniques de
développement personnel et c'est grâce à
une amie formatrice qui organise un
séminaire à moscou où il se fait inviter
qui découvre alors la russie accompagné
de sa deuxième femme d'origine
ukrainienne au cours de séjours
successifs dans le pays en particulier
dans la région de l'altaï qu'il
impressionne par sa beauté sauvage son
désir de venir s'y installer grandi eric
envisage tout d'abord de se lancer dans
la fabrication de fromages français
essuie même une formation mais il
comprend que ce n'est pas sa voie et il
revient à son domaine de prédilection le
développement personnel et décide
justement de créer un centre de
bien-être après une période de
préparation et d'élaboration de son
projet à moscou il s'installe finalement
en 2018 dans un petit village au coeur
de l'altaï
comment on vit ici qu'est-ce-qui qu'est
ce qui te manque commence à changer
d'avis on vit simplement ouais on vit
simplement et qu'est ce que ça a changé
ça a changé que
finalement
c'est ce que je recherchais aussi un
suivi plus lentement
plus simplement et j'ai peut-être plus
conscience de l'instant présent avant ce
n'était pas vraiment le cas en france
n'a pas été difficile au début je suis
bien sûr c'est difficile parce que c'est
un nouveau monde quand même
c'est ce et
les cultures sont différentes
les façons de faire les façons de parler
enfin je veux dire d'appréhender les
choses sont différentes et donc tu moi
j'ai quitté un monde que je connaissais
bien confronté à quelque chose que je
connaissais pas et que j'apprends tout
doucement faire mesure où chaque jour
jour après jour mais aux usa c'est pas
évident au début puis ce sont des
montagnards comment tu communiquer avec
les gens sur si natacha est pas là
les mains le mais j'utilise je fais pas
des jolies phrases en fait mais
j'utilise des mots qu'on imagier de
gamins âgés mille mots que je me répète
et puis bah quand je me débrouille quoi
je me débrouille mais je me débrouille
tuerie choix que le sourire oui beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup faut pas
parfois c'est vrai qu'ils ont des
comportements parfois houleux sourire va
vite vite régler les choses ça c'est
vrai mais en même temps je trouve qu'ils
sont très très patient quoi quand
j'arrive pas à dire les choses il
cherche le bout voilà et puis si je
trouve pas eh ben j'explique que je
sais mais bon là ça commence à me
manquer vraiment de parler de pouvoir
parler avec eux parce qu'on est dans une
relation aujourd'hui où ils ont envie de
partager beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup et
là il faut que je fasse quelque chose
dont j'ai une personne mais tu vois
régulièrement oui on va raconter des
bruits très exactement nerfs il sait pas
qui c'est vrai
[Musique]
salut eric
très bien moi ici
il va très bien il arriva
bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour swap
eliane un chanter j'ai fait la passe et
qu'est ce que c'est joli ici
c'est sacha mon mari
salut ça va
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour je suis sa chair dense
achat alors dit moi un petit peu qui est
marina pour toi qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
analyse agnès et deux personnes très
importantes pour nous 1 quand on est
arrivé ici c'était vraiment les
premières personnes qui nous ont
accueillis à bras ouverts
je tiens je tiens à dire en plus leur
maison les magic avec avec les
créativités d2 et sagna qui travaillent
le bois c'est une maison de comptes tu
vois et le même temps les personnages
aussi sur des personnages de contes pour
moi mais au bon sens du terme je trouve
ça magnifique et en même temps un hamac
et niestlé elle a passé toute sa
carrière comme sage femme et c'était
aussi quelqu'un qui est très très féru
dans l'utilisation des sangsues
matt erika natacha ils sont arrivés dans
notre village on a fait connaissance et
on a trouvé tout de suite des thèmes
communs donc vous voyez eric souvent
vous l'aidez souvent
bah oui on bavarde ce sont des gens très
intéressants
natacha raconte sa vie sasha et moi
aussi
le village est petit et nous avons une
communication limitée avec de telles
personnes et nous sommes très heureux
[Musique]
les alsaciens sont chamanistes et selon
leurs croyances le monde est peuplé
d'esprits bons et mauvais et les chamans
sur les intermédiaires entre eux et les
hommes
nous sommes avec eric sur ce qu'on
appelle la terre du chaman c'est un lieu
d'énergie pour les chamans locaux
la terre du chaman c'est juste de
l'autre côté de la rivière beaucoup de
chaman sont venus ici pour pratiquer
voire même un s'est installé à une
époque ici est pratiqué la danse dans
l'entrée de la grotte avec la marque et
il y en a beaucoup dans la région
comment ça se passe alors le très gros
avantage d'habiter ici depuis quelques
années
c'est d'avoir eu la chance grâce aux
locaux de rencontrer les vrais ça ils
sont pas beaucoup
réellement je connais deux c'est que les
gens qui
ont des soucis oui s'ouvre aux chamans
oui pour être guéri c'est ça ça peut
être un désordre physique psychologique
on sait que c'est souvent lire voilà et
lui va va proposer une façon et des
moyens pour que la personne puisse
retrouver un confort de vie au niveau de
sa problématique c'est ce que tu
retrouves toi cédant dans ta quête des
médecines alternatives si willy oui
parce que le grand déclic 1 après avoir
été formé surtout en programmation neuro
linguistique le grand déclic à ce qui
s'est passé au baïkal où j'ai rencontré
chemin d'un village et j'ai discuté avec
ce chaman on a parlé de ce que moi je
pratique en pnl et de ce que lui fait
est que
etc et les traditions les protocoles
qu'on lui a passées de génération en
génération et je me suis aperçu que
finalement ce que moi je pratique c'est
peut-être un petit morceau on est dans
un contexte complètement différent mais
on fait la même chose mais je pense que
là c'est la source de tout ce qu'on a pu
apprendre en europe la source aller là
et écoute voilà je t'emmène pour
traverser la rivière ouais
l'eau à l'air vraiment purge les bus
elle est magnifique il ya des sources
savez comment ça se passe les sources
sont accessibles l'altaï c'est comme
c'est comme un cerveau tu as un réseau
deux rivières de ruisseaux des puits de
source extraordinaire en fait si tu
voles l'image du cerveau avec toutes les
irrigations à la taille c'est ça c'est
pour ça que certains de l'appel aussi le
cerveau du monde en fait ici en tout cas
les haltères
[Musique]
oh
tu me racontes est un petit peu qui est
cette personne qu'est ce qu'on a ce soir
comme concert je pense que c'est
vraiment l'âme de l'altaï enfin c'est
quelque chose de qui sort vraiment de
des profondeurs en fait c'est lié avec
ce que fait alors oui c'est c'est eh oui
c'est bien qu'ils insistent là-dessus
pourquoi parce que à un moment donné à
l'excès pendant son cancer dit que sa
musique
thérapeutique et ça ça fait énormément
de liens en fait avec mon passé et le
présent ici si j'ai bien compris la le
concert ça va rayonner dans tout le
village alors ça c'est très important
aussi sage ans que les gens mais moi je
trouve que je ne sais pas ça mais par
contre au delà de ça je trouve que pour
nos jeunes pour ses habitants se sont et
pour les montagnes qui sont autour de
nous c'est je trouve que c'est un vrai
cadeau que l'excellent nous fait allez
viens on va s'asseoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui te manque le plus en
russie
je les dires les pains au chocolat et
les croissants mais ça n'est pas vrai
non mais c'est les amis bien évidemment
ils sont loin un mal malgré les moyens
de communication c'est vrai que j'aime
bien le contact donc
et puis vu le contexte international ces
voix là je les sens un peu loin et ça me
manque un totalement un trait de
caractère que tu apprécies chez les
russes le col le côté
enfant qu'ils ont gardé en qu'est ce que
lâche l'altaï a changé dans ta vie elle
a ravivé une
info qui s'était plus ou moins atteint
là bas quelques milliers de kilomètres
il y avait encore de beaux raisins mais
ça a ravivé cette braise et c est
redevenu un feu eric un grand merci ce
fut extraordinaire on a passé un moment
sublime du canton bravo cet effet
plaisir et puis tu es le bienvenu et
puis il raconte pas partout que c'est un
paradis promis
[Musique]
et voilà notre émission touche à sa fin
nous n'avons passé avec un incroyable
invité éric fritz qui nous a fait
découvrir les mystères de l'altaï sur
les terres du chaman de nouveaux lieux
de nouvelles personnalités tout aussi
intéressante de vous attendre je vous
dis à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
oh